[Music]
all right let's go out to Dallas Texas
and talk to Jamie what's up
Jamie hi Dr John this is Jamie how are
you I'm great how are you I'm doing good
so my thank you for taking my call by
the way of course thanks for calling
what's up um my question is how do I
balance working on getting out of debt
and active member of AA going to
counseling and being a good wife and
mother and um here's my backstory so I
met my husband during the beginning of
Co um we got married eight months um
after meeting which was January 10th of
2021 and both of us have children or or
I have a child from another relationship
his kids are now 23 18 and 16 years
years old why I have a
20-year-old all all the kids live
outside our home uh we both brought debt
into our relationship and we're
currently working on baby step number
two and we've been making progress on
that by the way um we are both working
about 55 to 65 hours a week I struggled
with drinking alcohol which led to some
chronic um health issues I've been sober
since no mber 27th 2021 all right
where'd it go yeah yeah so like in two
days get your yeah you're about to get
your two-year chip here in a month or
two yeah congratulations man that's
awesome thank you it's been it's been
and when I and when I say I'm an active
member like I have a
sponsor I actually have a sponsy i chair
meetings I mainly go to women's meetings
but sometimes I do co-ed so like I'm
there like I'm working the program it's
not just oh yeah go in once a time you
know I mean I'm I'm present so I show up
um and so it's been really hard work um
and I I go to counseling um and I know
that these changes have strengthened my
husband a nice
relationship even though I know being
debt free and staying sober is worth it
and it is worth it um there are days I I
just want to do nothing and start over
or just run I'm just tired
yes that feeling is that feeling is
right yeah yeah so that's my that's the
gist of it so hear me say this you're
not broken there's nothing wrong with
you if you weren't having those days I
would think you probably should see
somebody right
now right because the person who is
Jamie is not working right um how do you
define be a good wife and good mom
because the things that you just rattled
off there that you're trying to create
peace in your home by paying off all
your debts and for those of you who
don't know baby step 2 is a part of a
program called Financial Peace
University and baby step two is a death
Sprint to sell everything to work like
crazy no restaurants nothing to pay off
everything you owe so that you don't owe
anybody except for your mortgage um how
long do you have to go on that Jamie
so we are tackling our lost credit card
I I when I looked at every dollar I want
to say um we had a little we started off
with a little over
100k and yeah it was a little bit of
everything that's all right that's all
right but where are you now you now
we're about 80 a little over
80,000 left or that's what you've paid
off that is how much we we have left
okay so so you're 20% in right that's
right right correct very cool how long
you been working on it um well at first
we was kind of off and on but then we
both sold two expensive cars I missed
the
Camaro but nobody misses a Camaro that's
the most Dallas thing I've ever
heard
I I uh the guy who plays second string
tight end in his high school football
team that's who drives
Camaros right but we sold a 2021 Camaro
and a 2021 Trailblazer which took off a
lot of that and then um we also had a
lot of medical I had some significant
health issues hold on hold on hold on
you're circling the question how do you
define being a good mom and a good wife
oh how do I
Define I guess
being I guess being being
present okay but sometimes you're in a
fight for your life yeah and before you
can be present your body would be
failing you if it let you sit in peace
in your living room with your loved ones
knowing you owed a $100,000 in credit
card debt in car debt depreciating
assets it would be failing you if it
wasn't slowly sounding the alarms you're
not okay you're not okay you're not
okay right because you've been a few
drinks in and all a sudden something's
happening your body has a GPS pin in
that moment and it knows you can get
fired at any moment for anything right
and if you owe that kind of money then
they take everything right so your
body's doing exactly what it should be
and you're going to counseling and
working on how you re-experience the
world and you're going to AA and
learning from the from the foundation up
how to re-experience being
alive right that's incredible there's
not going to be be any balance in this
season then there shouldn't
be because you're running for your life
you're healing you're growing it's like
looking down like after you got a bad
cut and it's and it's and it's got a
scab on it and you're like when does the
smooth skin arrive and it's like later
right it's still
healing and that doesn't the scab
doesn't mean it's it's broken and man
scabs are the worst when you bump them
and they start bleeding again right or
you scratch them through your shirt
because you just forget about it and it
bleeds into your shirt like the worst
and also it's a sign that your body's
healing you're on the
path here's what I think
happening often when we make control alt
delete Life Changes I'm going to start
losing weight I'm going to start a
workout plan I'm going to be a better
husband I'm going to stop drinking I'm
going to go to AA I'm going start going
to counseling it feels so freaking good
for a week or
two right it's like you can take on the
world and then the reality sets in this
is every day for the rest of your
life and it's boring and it's annoying
and it's so frustrating and then slowly
but surely from underneath those
relationships and new programs the shame
demons come out and they're like if you
hadn't done this this long ago this
wouldn't have happened and if you had
have bought that you had done this right
they're hollering at you right yeah oh
yeah so it's a matter of we're going to
get through this we're going to pay off
everything we
owe so that we can our bodies can go
in our own living
rooms drop our shoulders and then you're
going to find balance restored in a
pretty powerful way but it's not going
to be balanced like you think it's not
going to be pain-free balance it's going
to be peace so that I you can handle the
nonsense as it comes has counseling
started getting
hard yeah it is cu it's yeah and I'm
actually um
yeah so like
we're like just and one of the things
I'm working with my counselor is getting
more Tools in my toolbox as far as how
to work through anxiety or depression or
just perfect communication communication
with my husband and my kids and perfect
my relationship even with my
stepchildren and my biological child has
changed dramatically you know um in good
ways and so I've just been trying to
learn how to do things different because
cuz the way you were doing them in the
past was going to kill you right and
right just know like you've started
playing football without a helmet on
right like you've been running through
life with a helmet on and the helmet was
alcohol and now you don't have that
anymore of course it's going to hurt the
first few times yeah right the first
time your step kid says something or
your husband's late getting home or
filling the the blank it's going to hurt
more because your your pseud of armor is
gone right and man I'm so proud of you
for already noticing I just got to learn
some new tools I got to learn some new
tools as I head into this thing that's
fantastic hang on the line I'm going to
send you a copy of building a
non-anxious life my new book on anxiety
um and I'm also going to send you own
your past change your future just about
navigating some of those stories and
that's going to give you some language
you can talk to your counselor with
um I think that idea of balance is a
complete and utter myth it's nonsense
it's not real it's something sold to us
by the Pinterest Instagram
snap fancy magazine at your like health
food store community and I just lumped a
bunch of people that really have nothing
to do with it but all in the same bucket
here's the deal there's no such thing
you can't be a millionaire and show up
to every build a a million dollar
business and show up to every um Lally
game and be the perfect wife and make
sure you cook all the meals and have be
the perfect husband and make sure that
you never get frustrated and the lawn is
always perfect that's not real it's not
real it's not
real and so for me I'm on the road I go
hard go hard go hard go hard and then
this weekend I spent six hours mowing my
yard with a with a riding
mower because it's six acres and it's a
lot and I'm just Mowing and Mowing and
Mowing and I did it a good job on it but
there's no balance I couldn't do that
and do this and do this and do this I
can't so when you're getting out of debt
you're hauling you're running for your
life no
restaurants no no spending money on
dates we're going to go on free dates
and my God how many laps are around the
creek before the lake before you're like
GH you're so cheap like it's the worst
but it
is and you're going to work 55 hours a
week and then you might deliver pizzas
in the evening or drive lift in the
morning before work you're going to just
grind it until that $80,000 is zero and
it's going to start piling up and piling
up and piling up you've already knocked
off 20 something thousand bucks and
you're on your
way and then there's going to be peace
just in time for the next big whatever
crazy thing is going to
happen but trying to beat yourself up
because like I'm not a good mom because
I'm not in Balance no dude you're in a
freaking amazing mom cuz you said this
hurt stops with me you're an incredible
wife because you looked at your husband
and said you deserve all of me and I got
to go find all of me first and so you're
going to AA you're going to counseling
I'm so proud of you it doesn't get any
better than
that and you're learning some new skills
you're going to have to practice there's
going to be some up days and some down
days and that's okay you're doing a
great great
job stay on the
path
even when you don't feel like it even
when it's frustrating even when those
old shame demons come screaming at you
stay on the path keep taking the next
step and the next step and the next step
they say in AA all the time it's one day
at a time it's one hour at a time it's
one minute at a
time that goes for any great things that
we pull off in our lives from changing
our marriages from changing our finances
from changing our physical health all of
it I'm proud of you
Jamie